let's learn a little bit about the
wonderful world of logarithms so we
already know how to take exponents if I
were to say 2 to the 4th power what does
that mean well that means 2 times 2
times 2 times 2 2 multiplied or
repeatedly multiplied 4 times and so
this is going to be 2 times 2 is 4 times
2 is 8 times 2 is 16 but what if we
think about things in another way what
if we're essentially we know that we get
to 16 when we raise 2 to some power and
we want to know what that power is so
for example let's say that I start with
2 and I say I'm raising it to some power
what does that power have to be to get
16 well we just figured that out
you would X would have to be X X would
have to be 4 and this is what logarithms
are fundamentally about figuring out
what power you have to raise to to get
another number now the way that we would
denote this with logarithm notation is
we would say log base actually let me
make that let me make it a little bit
more colorful log base 2 logs on this 2
in blue log base 2 of 16 of 16 of 16 is
equal to what or is equal in this case
since we have the X there is equal to X
this and this are completely equivalent
statements this is saying hey well if I
take 2 to some x power I get 16 this is
saying what power do I need to raise 2
to to get 16 and I'm going to set that
to be equal to X and you would say well
you got to raise it to the fourth power
once again X is equal to 4 so with that
out of the way let's try more examples
of evaluating logarithmic expressions so
let's say you had let's say you had log
base 3 log base 3 of 81
what would this evaluate to well this is
a reminder this evaluates to the power
we have to raise 3 to to get to 81 so if
you want to you could set this to be
equal to an X set that to be equal to
the next and you can restate this
equation as 3 as 3 to the X power 3 to
the X power is equal to 81 why is a
logarithm useful and you'll see that it
has very interesting properties later on
but you didn't necessarily have to use
algebra to do it this way to say that
the x is the power that you raise 3 to
to get to 81 you had to use algebra here
well with the just a straight up
logarithmic expression you didn't really
have to use in the algebra we didn't
have to set it equal to X we could just
say this evaluates to the power I need
to raise 3 to to get to 81 the power I
need to raise 3 to to get to 81 well
what power do you have to raise 3 to to
get to 81
well let's experiment a little bit so 3
to the first power is just 3 3 to the
second power is 9 3 to the third power
is 27 3 to the fourth power 27 times 3
is equal to 81 3 to the fourth power is
equal to 81 X is equal to 4 so we could
say log base 3 base 3 of 81 of 81 is
equal to I'll do this in the new color I
haven't have used almost every color is
equal to 4 let's do several more of
these examples and I really encourage
you to give a shot on your own now that
we get and you'll hopefully get the hang
of it so let's try some a little larger
number let's say we want to take log
base 6 of 216 what will this evaluate to
well we're asking ourselves what power
do we have to raise 6 to to get to 216 6
to the first power 6 6 to the second
power is 36
thirty-six times six is 216 this is
equal to 216 so this is six to the third
power is equal to 216 so if someone says
what power do have to raise six to this
base here to get to 216 well that's just
going to be equal to three six to the
third power is equal to 216
let's try another one let's say I had I
don't know log base 2 of 64 so what does
this evaluate to well once again we are
asking ourselves so this will evaluate
to the exponent that I have to raise
this base two and you do this is this
little subscript right here the exponent
that after erase to two to get to 64 so
2 to the first power is 2 to the second
power is 4 8 16 32 64 so this right over
here is 2 to the sixth power is equal to
64 so when you evaluate this expression
you say what power to have to raise 2 to
to get to 64 well I have to raise it I
have to raise it to the 6th power let's
do it slightly let's do a slightly more
straightforward one
or maybe this will be less
straightforward depending on how you
view it what is log base 100 of 1 let
you think about that for a second and
this one so the hundred is the subscript
of them.the it's log base 100 of 1
that's one way to think about I could
put a parenthesis around the 1 what does
this evaluate - well this is asking
ourselves or we would evaluate this as
what power to have to raise 10 to today
sorry what part enough to raise a
hundred - to get to 1 so let me write
this down as an equation so if I set
this to be equal to X this is literally
saying hundred - what power is equal to
1 well anything that the zeroth power is
equal to 1 so in this case X is equal to
0 so log base 100 of 1
is going to be equal to zero log base
anything of one is going to be equal to
zero because anything to the zeroth
power and we're not talking about zero
here anything to the zeroth power is
that's not zero is going to be equal to
one